60 YEARS AGO THIS OCTOBER, "WEST
SIDE STORY" WAS RELEASED.
IT WOULD GO ON TO WIN
TEN COMPETITIVE OSCARS,
MOST FAMOUSLY FOR
BEST SUPPORTING ACTRESS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AMONG ITS OTHER SMALLER AWARDS
WAS BEST PICTURE OF THE YEAR,
AND THAT IS WHAT I AM
HERE TO PRESENT.
“THE FATHER” DAVID PARFITT,
JEAN-LOUIS LIVI, AND PHILLIPE
CARCASSONNE, PRODUCERS.
"JUDAS AND THE BLACK
MESSIAH” SHAKA KING,
CHARLES D. KING, AND
RYAN COOGLER, PRODUCERS.
“MANK” CEAN CHAFFIN,
ERIC ROTH, AND DOUGLAS
URBANKSI, PRODUCERS.
“MINARI” CHRISTINA OH,
PRODUCER.
“NOMADLAND” FRANCES
MCDORMAND, PETER SPEARS,
MOLLYE ASHER, DAN JANVEY,
AND CHLOE ZHAO, PRODUCERS.
“PROMISING YOUNG WOMAN”
BEN BROWNING, ASHLEY FOX,
EMERALD FENNELL, AND
JOSEY MCNAMARA,
PRODUCERS.
“SOUND OF METAL”
BERT HAMELINCK AND
SACHA BEN HARROCHE, PRODUCERS.
“THE TRIAL OF THE CHICAGO 7"
MARC PLATT AND
STUART BESSER, PRODUCERS.
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
“NOMADLAND”
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
ON BEHALF OF MY FELLOW
PRODUCERS, PETER SPEARS,
MOLLYE ASHER, DAN JANVEY,
AND THE ONE AND ONLY
FRANCES MCDORMAND,
WE THANK THE ACADEMY
AND WE THANK OUR BRILLIANT
FELLOW NOMINEES AND
WE THANK ALL THE HEARTS
AND HANDS THAT COME TOGETHER
TO MAKE THIS MOVIE.
FROM SEARCHLIGHT PICTURES.
JESSICA BRUDER, WHO TRUSTED
US WITH HER BEAUTIFUL BOOK.
TO OUR BRILLIANT CINEMATOGRAPHER
JOSHUA JAMES RICHARDS.
AND TO THE ENTIRE
“NOMADLAND” COMPANY.
WE WANT TO SHOW OUR
DEEPEST GRATITUDE TO LINDA MAY,
SWANKIE, BOB WELLS,
AND NOMADIC COMMUNITY,
ALL THE PEOPLE WE MET ON
THE ROAD.
THANK YOU FOR TEACHING
US THE POWER OF RESILIENCE AND
HOPE, AND FOR REMINDING US
WHAT TRUE KINDNESS LOOKS LIKE.
AND NOW I GIVE YOU FERN.
>> NO, I’M NOT.
I’M FRAN.
PLEASE WATCH
OUR MOVIE ON THE LARGEST
SCREEN POSSIBLE AND ONE DAY
VERY, VERY SOON, TAKE EVERYONE
YOU KNOW INTO A THEATER, SHOULDER
TO SHOULDER IN THAT DARK SPACE
AND WATCH EVERY FILM THAT’S
REPRESENTED HERE TONIGHT.
WE GIVE THIS ONE TO OUR WOLF
[HOWLS]